bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors comment
interprétez-vous cette visite officielle
de la turquie en libye sion si ça fait
suite à la déclaration effectivement du
maraîcher l'aft a un qui à l'occasion du
69e anniversaire de l'indépendance du
pays où il évoquait la nécessité de
justement de reprendre éventuellement
les armes pour bouter le colonisateur je
cite hors de la libye en l'occurrence en
faisant allusion à la présence future
que du côté aux côtés du gouvernement du
gn à tripoli on peut rappeler que la
turquie a de base une base terrestre
avec al watyah qui a été reprise
maintenant comment l'année et une base
maritime sur misrata donc c'est il ya
une présence turque effectivement qui
est qui est importante et il se trouve
que le parlement d'ankara a voté la
prolongation 18 mois delà du déploiement
des militaires turcs donc il ya il ya
une effervescence autour de cette
situation qui est qui est à l'origine en
partie de la déclaration du maraîcher
daf tard et puis de la visite inattendue
juste après 2 du ministre de la défense
turque eux à tripoli alors qu'elles font
les objectifs de la thur ton en libye
les objectifs ont été établis depuis un
an déjà dans le cadre de l'accord qui a
été signé avec alsa rage c'était un
soutien effectivement contre l'offensive
notamment du mariage de la star sur la
ville de tripoli à partir de 2019
offensif qui a été stoppée en juin 2020
justement grâce à l'intervention sur le
terrain opérationnel des conseillers
turcs avec l' usage le recours aux
drones notamment dont il y avait il ya
effectivement de ce point de vue là une
présence turque eux renforcé qui
justifie de l'autre côté des des
rodomontades du maréchal et puis le le
fait d'être appuyés par des pays comme
l'egypte et en arrière-plan le notamment
les émirats
donc il y avait pourtant une
leur d'espoir la faveur d'une bonne de
vente puisque l'onu stephenie williams
avait évoqué le 19 novembre le fait que
l'oignon entendez des avantages de
langage de la paix manifestement les
choses sont en train de déraper
potentiellement et c'est tout le
problème
alors aftam qui veut chasser l'occupant
la turquie qui menace de répondre est ce
que on a une escalade militaire en vue
qui est possible il ya en tout cas une
escalade verbale militaire pour
l'instant on en est pas encore là mais
rien est exclu et il ya des signes qui
sont pas encourageants c'est notamment
le celui qui devait succéder à hassan
sallam et qu'ils étaient donc avait
démissionné entre comme représentant de
l'onu en mars dernier nikolay mladenov
vient de jeter l'épongé alors même
qu'ils venaient d'être jetés
officiellement adoubé par l'onu il a
décidé de renoncer à son poste le 21
décembre au motif supposer que certains
libyens considéré qu'il n'était plus
trop favorable au camp pro haftar donc
il ya des incertitudes qui prévalent et
cette démission n'est pas bon signe de
ce point de vue là parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'espoir qui émergeait avec le
forum de dialogue dans les réunions
comme en novembre avait été plutôt
plutôt fructueuse alors on a
actuellement un pays scindé en deux ans
d'à côté le jeune a reconnu par la
communauté internationale de l'autre le
maréchal stable qui lui aussi ses
soutiens
est ce que des élections comme c'est
prévu je pense le 24 décembre 2021 donc
une solution pacifique
est-ce que cela va permettre une réelle
sortie de crise pour la libye bah c'est
l'objectif affiché par un par l'onu et
par les parties en présence
avec toutes les incertitudes qui
aujourd'hui reçurent juste puisque
manifestement il ya déjà des difficultés
à mettre en place la structure pour pour
amener justement la préparation des
futures élections législatives et
présidentielles pour la fin d'année
prochaine et donc ça va dépendre de
l'évolution effectivement en termes
politiques et militaires et de ce point
de vue là il ya beaucoup il ya un point
d'interrogation qui aujourd'hui est
posée d'autant plus que le cadrage le
forum
de dialogue et les 75 membres qui ont
été qui ont été donc sélectionner une
partie des critiques peser sur le fait
qu' il y avait un rôle potentiellement
trop important de de gens proches de
l'islam politique
et puis par ailleurs il y avait une
sous-représentation des tribus touareg
et tout goût du sud dont il y avait un
déséquilibre
même si l'onu avait validé 49 de ses 75
membres de la société civile donc il ya
un processus qui est lancé avec beaucoup
d'obstacles encore aujourd'hui alors
très rapidement les nations unies dont
tous à quel est leur véritable marge de
manoeuvre est est ce que leur position
est claire
aujourd'hui la position des nations
unies est claire oui de toute façon le
processus s'inscrit dans là dans la
réunion de berlin dans le prolongement
la réunion de berlin de du début d'année
à savoir le respect de l'embargo sur les
armes à destination de la libye
justement avec des contrôles dans le
cadre de l'opération maritime irigny qui
parfois donne yeux d'ailleurs à des
frictions avec la turquie
et puis le lancement du processus
politique avec la possibilité de nommer
un conseil présidentiel
trois membres pour l'instant les choses
ne sont pas établis et donc il ya aussi
des les paramètres de logiques
personnelles que ça soit la part du
maréchal haftar ou ou deux dans le camp
du gène a donc il ya pour l'instant des
parasites et des hypothèques qui ne sont
pas levés merci david rigoulet roze
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur à
l'ifan chercheur associé à l'iris
rédacteur en chef de la revue aurions
stratégique mais recèle aussi